[Musik]
hallo herr zielke sallys welt heute gibt
es eine weihnachtliche torte ich habe
hier einen baumkuchen torte okay ich
weiß es worte schon ein bisschen doppelt
gemoppelt waldbauern kuchen und torte
naja egal ist was ich meine
jedenfalls habe ich hier im innern einen
baumkuchen und zwar ist es ein kuchen
der schicht für schicht gebacken wird
und dann beim aufschneiden eben aussieht
wie so ein aufgeschnittener baum also
ein baumstamm und die torte ist gefüllt
mit physalis mails mandarinen und die
creme habe ich gemacht mit cent also
einem gericht leckere zimt creme und von
der deko her ist sie auch gar nicht so
aufwendig und wirklich super lecker ich
denke ich mal die zutaten die ihr für
den bau kuchen benötigt für den baum
kuchenteig verwende ich viel eiweiß eine
prise salz 50 gramm zucker 150 g weiche
butter 100 gramm zucker etwas meinl
extrakt vier eigelbe etwas orangensaft
oder contro zum beispiel 150 gramm mehl
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver etwas
topcar bohne und den abrieb einer
unbehandelten orange
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal das eiweiß
das wird nämlich getrennt steif
geschlagen gebe ich jetzt in der saubere
schüssel mit etwas salz und kann es kurz
steif schlagen
und sobald der schnee fest ist kommt
dann noch der zucker langsam dazu und
wird etwa eine minute mit eingerührt
[Musik]
da jetzt der eischnee richtig schön fest
mache ich einen kurzen schüssel wechsel
hier kommt jetzt die weiche butter rein
dann der übrige zucker und etwas vanille
extrakt und hier können jetzt die
zutaten auch für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten cremig verrührt werden sobald
die butter zucker masse schaumig es
kommen jetzt noch die eigelbe
nacheinander dazu
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch der orangenschalen
ab da ist nur wichtig dass die orange
unbehandelt ist damit man die schale mit
verstärkt haben dann etwas orangensaft
oder auch rum oder contro zum beispiel
die zutaten kurz unterheben
jetzt gebe ich hier auch die trockenen
zutaten mit reinen also backpulver und
mehl erstmal nur die hälfte unterheben
und dann kommt da noch der schnee mit
dazu und ein bisschen tonkabohne
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich eine richtig schöne
luftigen teig berichten ganz ganz tolle
rührteig und jetzt kommen die baum
schichten dran der beziehung backform
bereits auf 24 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und auch eine back folie und
ein backblech gegeben
das nehme ich immer zwei esslöffel etwa
vom teig kommt jetzt hier rein wird
schön glatt gestrichen mit der palette
jetzt wird dieser teig gebacken und zwar
habe ich jetzt den backofen bereits auf
grillfunktion gestellt dann dauert es so
etwa zwei bis drei minuten ich bleibe
auf jeden fall immer dabei stehen und
sobald die oberfläche brown ist kommt
die nächste portion tag darauf wieder
zwei bis drei esslöffel verstreichen und
wieder in den backofen und so werde
jetzt den kompletten tag einmal
aufbrauchen
[Musik]
es ist ein bisschen aufwendig aber es
lohnt sich
[Musik]
der baum corinne ist es gebacken und den
lasse ich jetzt komplett abkühlt und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
frucht füllung machen für die
fruchtbildung verwende ich 175 gramm
mandarinen aus der dose die habe ich
bereits abgetropft ich habe hierfür
saales und verwende 325 g geschälte für
salihs ich habe ich 100 milliliter von
mandarinen saft 200 milliliter
orangensaft und 30 gramm ager nehme ich
hier die pedale und nehmen sie aus der
schale heraus und setzte dann halbieren
dann werden die fußball ist einfach nur
halbiert wenn sie ganz groß sind dann
können das auch vierte und das ist
übrigens morales lieblings frucht also
fürs alles liebt da über alles jetzt
kann ich schon direkt in den topf und
werde jetzt hier zuerst die beiden
flüssigkeiten reingeben das ist der satz
den ich aus der dose aufgefangen haben
von den mandarinen und dann noch
orangensaft hier kommt jetzt noch ärger
mit dazu das ist das pflanzliche mittel
jetzt kurz verrühren und da gebe ich
jetzt auch direkt die physalis mit rein
damit die auch so ein bisschen zu kochen
können und auch den mandarinen jetzt
kurz den herd anstellen und dann
aufkochen lassen und mindestens zwei
minuten lang sprudelnd kochen
[Musik]
wer möchte kann die frucht füllung noch
ein bisschen verfeinern mit wally
extrakt und mit etwas zimt
[Musik]
und zu schauen ob die fruchtbildung
festwirt nehme ich jetzt ein bisschen
was davon gibt es auch einen kleinen
teller und so kann ich nicht probe
machen nicht stellt ganz kurz in den
kühlschrank und innerhalb von ein bis
zwei minuten wird es dann schön fest in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
form vorbereiten
ihr braucht es natürlich eine form mit
der er die frucht anlageformen könnt ich
nehme jetzt einfach einen tortenring den
habe ich auf 18 zentimeter eingestellt
stellen auf einen teller und unten dran
kommt ein bisschen frischhaltefolie
damit einfach nichts ausläuft und ich
das später wieder gut vom teller runter
bekommen die probe die ist schön fest
wie man hier sehen kann
hkk ist immer ganz wichtig wenn man mit
säure arbeitet mit essig oder
orangensaft zum beispiel dass man
einfach etwas mehr engagement mit eben
auch schon fest wird ansonsten verliert
das ganze nämlich nicht jetzt kann ich
hier die masse einfüllen
[Musik]
ihr könnt ihr natürlich vorher auch
gerne ein bisschen abkühlen lassen
lauwarm aber so funktioniert auch ganz
gut
jetzt stelle ich sie so ganz kurz zur
seite lasst sie etwas lauwarm abkühlen
und dann kommt die frucht einlage in den
gefrierschrank der baumkuchen ist
abgekühlt die frucht einlage ist auch
west jetzt kommt die zimt creme
ich hab mir das passiert ganz gut dazu
mit bisschen sternanis und ich werde
jetzt hier eine italienische buttercreme
zu bereiten für die zehn mit gram
verwende ich 170 gramm eiweiß 300 gramm
zucker etwas zimt und ein sternanis 500
gramm butter und 100 gramm puderzucker
das eiweiß kommt jetzt natürlich nicht
roh auf die torte sondern ich gehe es
hier in eine große schüssel
da kommt der zucker mit rein und für den
geschmack zimt und sternanis und ich
kann jetzt hier schon mal in einem topf
das wasser aufkochen lassen und hier die
zutaten einfach kurz berühren sieht
jetzt noch etwas viel zucker und etwas
viel eiweiß und butter aus aber am ende
wird echt ne richtig leckere creme die
passt dann wirklich hervorragend zur
flucht ein lager nichts hört ihr hier
auch schon die zuckerkristalle die reibe
mir so ein bisschen am schlüssel rand
jetzt kommt es hier über das heiße
wasser rat
da muss jetzt nur aufpassen dass es aber
nicht überkocht mit erhitzt sich hier
die eiweiß master für etwa zehn minuten
während dem rühren
also wirklich schön erhitzen und so
lösen sich noch auf die zuckerkristalle
auf und das eiweiß wird pasteurisiert
das heißt alle keime werden ihnen dann
auch abgetötet und das ist auch eine
richtig coole eiweiß resteverwertung
gerade zur winterzeit da macht man ja
auch mal plätzchen wo hat ganz viel
eiweiß übrig wir können das schon
verwertet
[Musik]
ich glaube ich nicht doch ein
handrührgerät so wird noch so anstrengen
anrühren
[Musik]
jetzt ist der schnell fertig und ich
habe jetzt auch schon den finger test
gemacht das heißt einfach ein bisschen
die zwischen den fingern verreiben
und wenn der zucker gelöst ist dann ist
er perfekt jetzt kann ich ihnen vom
wasserbad herunternehmen und muss die
masse jetzt einfach nur noch kalt rühren
das aber vorher einmal kurz den sternen
sie entfernen zum kalkül verwende ich
jetzt die küchenmaschine da kann ich sie
rühren lassen und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich dann schon mal die butter mit
dem zucker schaumig rühren
[Musik]
und der fahrt mit dem kalten ist
wirklich super wichtig da durch die
nicht zu ungeduldig sein also die creme
muss wirklich richtig schön abkühlen da
ansonsten die butter gleich schlimm ist
wenn ich gleich beides vermischen
[Musik]
die brücke jetzt einfach so lange rühren
bis schönweiß bremische
[Musik]
jetzt die butter schön weiß cremig und
die bc masse ist auch abgekühlt
jetzt kann ich beides verrühren sich
einfach schon super lecker hier
[Musik]
das habe ich hier den tortenboden der
bereits abgekühlt und stehen sehe ich
jetzt vom backpapier runter von der bak
folie jetzt so immer ganz einfach wenn
man es um schlägt und dann runter
wegrollt jetzt kenne ich die torte
direkt auf den torten retter setzen wenn
ihr möchtet könnt ihr den tortenboden
jetzt ein bisschen tränken mit
orangensaft contro oder rum zb wir dann
noch ein bisschen saftiger und
aromatischer und da kommt jetzt die
frucht einlage drauf
[Applaus]
[Musik]
darunter sieht man jetzt richtig schön
die vielen kleinen körnchen davon den
saal ist die frucht einlage kommt jetzt
hier direkt in die mitte
das geräusch im hintergrund des übrigen
zu tausenden sind gab murat erarbeitet
der garten wird jetzt endlich gemacht
jetzt kann ich die buttercreme nehmen
und in einen spritzbeutel füllen mit
einer großen lokale und dann habe ich
jetzt noch ein bisschen nougat genommen
habe den in einen gefrierbeutel gefüllt
und im warmen wasserbad geschmolzen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die creme hier direkt an
den rand
[Musik]
dann ein bisschen nougat drüber dafür
einfach die spitze vom gefrierbeutel
wegschneiden
[Musik]
dann wieder creme darüber und die frucht
einlage komplett abdecken
[Musik]
und den nutzt einfach so drüber laufen
lassen und dann können wir jetzt nämlich
eine palette nehmen und die torte auf
einem drehteller setzen und schön glatt
streichen
[Musik]
und so kommen die torte jetzt erstmal in
die kühle die buttercreme kann ich
abdeckungen bei raumtemperatur lagern
und so können wir die torte später dann
fertig dekorieren
[Musik]
die torte habe ich jetzt aus der torten
vor ausgelöst jetzt kommt die restliche
buttercreme an den rand und an die
oberfläche und es geht mit dem
spritzbeutel echt super
[Musik]
schön glatt streichen jetzt rächt sie
erst die oberfläche glatt mit einer
palette dann kommen die teig karte zum
einsatz die leg ich ziehe an den rand
und mit der drehbaren tortenplatte geht
es nun echt ganz gut jetzt nämlich die
winkel palette setzte hier oben an den
rand und sie so in die mitte und dann
bekommen und den rand auch schön
[Musik]
bereits die deko drankommt setzt sich
die torte erstmal auf die platte zwei
winkel paletten
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich eine kleine winkel
palette setzt hier an den rand und jetzt
drehe ich die tortenplatte und sie die
palette hoch
[Musik]
das gleiche auch in der mitte auf der
oberfläche
jetzt der chor ist die torte mit
bisschen zimt fertig skizziert ein
bischen reis kommt in ein kleines haus
so kann ich einfach verhindern dass zu
viel sind auf der torte landet dann hier
ein bisschen zimt rein
jetzt kann ich ganz vorsichtig dosieren
[Musik]
und ich glaube da ist einfach ein
bisschen fies alles drauf und sternanis
zum dekorieren mache ich jetzt einfach
mit schale drauf weil dieses feature
findet aber vor dem verzehr muss man
natürlich die schale entfernen zumal
ganz einfach hier hinten so ein kranz
und hasborn frei in den sternen dies
kann man hier oben drauf nicht mitessen
aber ich finde ihn einfach
superglücklich und später müsste ihn
nicht wegschmeißen ihr könnt dann später
abwaschen und können dann zum beispiel
glühwein oder kinderpunsch zum mitmachen
oder einfach wieder trocknen lassen
entweder das nächste mal weiter
verwenden
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt hier so fertig man kann
der murat schauen probieren
[Musik]
dass die torte probiert werden und da
der murat gerade mit seinem instagram
verkauf beschäftigt ist dürfen jetzt
sabine und selber problem
ich will doch im raum kommt herein könnt
ihr mir vielleicht seine torten schaufel
geben von hinten kommt rein ich weiß
aber sehr macht du musst dich zwischen
uns stellen weil sabine und integration
haben drückt und ich habe es absichtlich
gemacht haben was sich der mann zwischen
die zwei frauen stellen muss so sieht
jetzt die torte aus und hier unten seht
ihr ganz gut diesen baumkuchen mit den
einzelnen schichten der schicht für
schicht gebackenen immer zwei minuten
gewartet wieder offen auf teig drauf
extra für euch in der mitte haben hat
diese frucht einlage und außen rum die
zimmer schicht da vorne hat eine maus
reingebissen
schicht für schicht guck mal da ist
nicht schön ist es alles was das magazin
weiter wieder vollständig mit creme als
ihr müsst so alles so kommen oder ja
[Musik]
ja ab ob ihr euch nochmal so sind und
sternanis lugano hat habe ich noch so
rein gestützt hier stecken aber es
schmeckt alles frei so dass es noch
besser
na ja ich hab noch wissen was übrig so
klein dass man gar nicht was die beste
projekt ist gut wird die torte auch
machen sabine irgendwann doch sehr
publikum machen nicht aber es ja das
sieht man nur einmal so im rhein
gestürzt und hat sich so ein bisschen
verbunden
also falls ihr die torte auch mal
nachmachen wollt dann schaut auch handys
- blog.de vorbei das ist übrigens ein
tier markt der zum beispiel meinen
interest account immer fünf als er nimmt
dann die rezepte vom block und die
bilder und dann wechselt er da richtig
coole pins und der sewag dass er schon
winterfest experte gern und sabine die
kennt ja auch schon
sabine ist unsere freundin aus oberndorf
am neckar also eigentlich was früher mal
murats freundin nur schavan und sabine
sind eigentlich monats freunde aber
mittlerweile stimmung hat so gemein zu
denen das ist eigentlich noch wegen mir
kommen herr sabine samira kiste samira
vom ballett abholen sie steckt genau
deswegen genau deswegen oder deswegen
kommen sie eigentlich nur noch wegen mir
wegen den kindern als nachfragt warum
ist für mich war nur spaß wissen woraus
ledigen den murat auch wenn er kennt
denn ja und ich meine ihr habt schon
seit 200 jahren 20 jährigen erst seit
entferne dabei ja ja ja ist aber gut mit
ihm aus wir fragen uns echt auf die
modistin ja ich glaube es war weil wir
oft einfach so weg hören
da herrscht oft einfach weg und spürt es
nicht gehen das ist zu viel und wir
machen auch unsere schluss fotos und an
der reihe
[Musik]
aha
einfach silly ich backe jetzt die
schränke der angebrochene packungen
abgelaufenen zutaten jeder hat seine
rest der schublade und du hast schon
eine idee was wir damit machen
nein sally improvisiert alles nur aus
resten und zaubert ein außergewöhnliches
kuchenbuffet daran warum was als
restaurant
einfach sally sonntag 16 uhr bei vox